thank you thank you I need that tonight
I really do I because this week I I
can't I just get I'm gonna tell dog and
cat jokes I just I I mean I have heard
the phrase people say that this guy
would lie about the weather I didn't
think I'd ever see it literally I'm not
from the president
I'm so glad football is back because
finally some brain damage we can
actually enjoy season football season
started last night the Bears against the
Packers Mike Pence said he is not gonna
watch that game he said
well for those of you in the Midwest the
punch line is bears-packers that's too
gay that say these people know about
that stuff anyway Mike Pesci Mike Pence
spent all week in Europe this is just
the side scandal to the weather scandal
see Trump was supposed to go to Europe
to commemorate the 80th anniversary of
the start of World War two in Poland he
decided he couldn't go because we needed
his giant brain to monitor the storm
that was about to hit Alabama so pence
went and the first stop Ireland pence
stayed 200 miles from where his meeting
was because he had to stay in a Trump
Hotel and you know Trump hotels very
different from regular hotels when you
call down to room service for ice a team
of immigration police show up
anyway anyway Trump did not go on the
trip he said he couldn't he had to
monitor the storm and he went golfing
and the storm durian okay
it was looked like it was about to hit
Florida was barreling right toward
Florida and it just stopped over the
poor people in the Bahamas it was like
you know that's like 15 miles away was
heading right toward Florida and it just
looked at Florida and went no we're not
[ __ ] with Florida I'm sorry I mean
we've we've seen hurricanes turn this is
the first one that pretended it was on
its phone America got lucky we missed
the worst of it the Carolinas got a lot
of rain half a million people in the
Carolinas are totally without power
but enough about disenfranchising voters
how'd you do reminds me and you see this
story drum for the second time in a
month
Trump has awarded the Presidential Medal
of Freedom to a white NBA player a
couple weeks ago he did for Bob Cousy
who was a great player and yesterday to
Jerry West also a great player but least
racist person in the world I am is that
the right moniker for someone who cannot
find a good black basketball player
anyway back to the storm the party that
I'm trying to avoid which it's a [ __ ]
depressing is that Trump because he's an
excitable housebound senior citizen when
it was starting up saw on the TV where
he gets all his information that it was
about to help hit Alabama so he told
everyone in Alabama to have run for
their lives and then of course it wasn't
going anywhere near alibi but because he
could never be wrong he doctored the map
freehand with a sharpie so when a fight
about a brain fart that he had five days
ago and that's when he went under the
tent for the concussion protocol
he has no moral compass and no compass
we laugh wait'll he does it with the
election map no serious if this guy was
president of a different country we
would bomb it that's my kind of audience
right there yeah there's of oxygen right
I killed her with that joke my songs
okay but I mean it gives the whole thing
really what the storm just shows how the
two parties are living in two completely
different realities while this
definitely global warming inspired
souped up storm was wiping out and yet
another Caribbean island Democrats who
are running for president had a town
hall about climate I said Democrats is
gonna be bad news and the bad news that
was during the town hall our frontrunner
eyeball exploded they didn't say this
Joe Biden you know what I'm talking
about he had his some sort of rupture in
his eyeball Oh for [ __ ] sake this
thing is this thing is falling apart we
haven't even driven it off the lot
I'm not making this up I saw the picture
joe biden's i ruptured he had a bloody
eyeball and Elizabeth Warren said
turning from white to red that's my
trick
you